in order to pass through Heaven you have
to go through hell in order to get to
the other side of fear you have to pass
right through it I always thought I
wanted to be a world champion in
multiple Sports I wanted to invent the
things that I ride I set a goal that's
outlandish and maybe impossible if those
targets feel too Grand and big I just go
back to the basics I remind myself
everything's baby steps and all of a
sudden I end up where I was supposed to
go I'm like this isn't that hard it's
because I did all the right things along
the way I like competition because it
becomes sort of like a little game and
and that I think pushes my Innovation
you see who you really are in that
moment I've been disappointed and I've
also been like kind of Blown Away the
person I've become